Well, good morning everyone and thank
you uh for allowing me to be here today.
Uh I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about the five soil health principles.
Um my name is Daryl Oswald and I manage
the Berley County Soil Conservation
District. I've been with the district
for 25 plus years. Uh I am also a farmer
and a rancher from northeast Berley
County, a fourth generation rancher. Uh
and
uh near wing
uh up there in the northeast corner and
and uh this particular slide
is to lead off as a picture of the
Manoken farm. Uh some of you or maybe
all of you are familiar uh with the uh
Manoken farm. Uh it's our conservation
demonstration
farm owned owned and operated by the
Berley County Soil Conservation
District. Going to lead off uh of
course we've talked about these a little
bit in the past and and in our egg
production
model in general and and mine included
on our farm and ranch uh which I'm going
to relate to most today. We have to have
some we have to identify our ecological
or our excuse me our agricultural
resource
concerns
and really these are symptoms of
landscape
simplification and you know leading off
of course we have the wind and water
erosion. Uh we still have that across uh
North Dakota quite readily. Of course,
uh we see it uh in Berley County and and
every county across the state. Uh the
salinity thing is really coming to to
roost for us and and that's become
troublesome. Uh our lack of plant
diversity and cover. Uh we've really
simplified the landscape and the crop
rotations. We've taken a lot of
livestock off the land and of course our
animal in impact.
Um and we can have a drought and a flood
in the same year which tells me uh as a
farmer and a rancher uh if I correlate
that to Oswald Ranch it tells me that I
don't have any resiliency in the system.
And of course
uh with that uh we had uh Lindsay talk
about carbon and of course carbon drives
the cycle or the system and of course
exporting carbon off your farm and
ranch. Uh again agriculture is an
extraction business. That's going to
happen. But we have to understand that
we have to put more carbon back into the
system than we take out. and that can
lead to carbon deficient soils. This is
a page out of the nature and properties
of soils um that I use quite readily and
again correlating back to my own farm
and ranch. You look at the factors
promoting the
gains and and losses of organic matter
in soils uh which helps drive the
system. And of course the gains is when
the soil health principles if you look
down that list I won't read them all but
uh as you look down that list you see
that the principles that we're going to
talk about uh really pertain to the
factors promoting the gains and really
have very little to do with any uh of
the factors promoting the losses. And um
the soil health principles again
uh I won't read them off to you but you
can see this slide has been around the
world and back many times and it
correlates to soil health and the soil
health
principles are universal.
uh we were having a discussion here with
the group uh this morning but you need
to scope them to your particular farm
and ranch and to your particular
situation. The principles work on any
scale large or small.
[Music]
Uh currently at the Manoken farm, uh our
urban gardening and our outdoor
gardening and our high tunnel gardening
all employ the soil health principles
and again working on a very large scale
uh excuse me small scale and so they are
very
uh universal in that regard.
We always lead off with the or at least
I do I always lead off with armoring the
soil uh as the number one principle. Uh
I believe that again you can't really
get the system going. You can't move it
forward until you start protecting the
soil. Uh this particular photo is off of
Oswald Ranch. Uh, this is a cover crop
that we did graze and I can assure you
that armoring the soil doesn't look like
that all the time at the ranch, but I
thought it was pretty vindictive or uh
in in a good indicator of where we like
to be on our ranch when it comes to
armoring the soil. And again, uh, this
happens to be crop
residue. And that's one way that you can
achieve armor. And of course the other
way would be by growing plants. U most
of the carbon in this dead litter goes
into the atmosphere as carbon
dioxide and of course uh the green
plants gives us an inlet for carbon
going into the soil. And uh again armor
uh is very very important and uh is
generally in my world is always led off
as the first principle. Uh here I've
shown an example again armor on our uh
farm and ranch pertains a lot to how we
graze. Uh we do we do do some farmland
or crop land or some annual cropping. Uh
but we do uh way more grazing. And this
particular photo I think uh shows the
armor on the native uh graze native
range that we like to try to achieve and
we're out there.
Uh one of my mentors uh Jean Govin from
Turtle Lake uh used to say that his goal
was to capture every raindrop where it
falls and uh we've kind of taken the
same mantra but Oswald Ranch and we feel
that this is the way that we can do this
and again we're reducing our evaporation
rates uh our soil temperatures uh we
built more resiliency in the system uh
during the drier periods because of the
armor that we have on and uh we can
reduce this the temperature. We're not
uh evaporating the water uh per se and
as Carlos stated this is generally a
very very good provide great habitat for
the soil food web and uh we think it's
very important. So this is how we employ
armor uh on our operation minimizing
soil disturbance. Uh again I put an
emphasis on physical disturbance
because that is the thing that we
generally relate the most to. Uh we do
have to work I I believe uh across uh
our production model in eliminating
physical disturbance as much as we can.
We know that tillage removes pore spaces
and and uh slowly compresses the soil
much like if we were building the road.
Uh we talk about water infiltration and
air movement and of course tillillage
restricts all of that. And then of
course it takes off any of the soil
armor uh that we did have in our
previous
uh and first soil health principle. And
I think someone said too that when we
till or disturb we release a burst of
carbon dioxide resulting in carbon loss.
And of course we want to more carbon
coming into the system than going out.
Uh physical con disturbance can also or
excuse me uh soil disturbance can also
be related to I think uh too much uh
chemical use uh pesticide use uh that
scenario as well uh too much overg
grazing I think that we uh we when we
see seasonl long grazing uh we see soil
disturbance in some places and not at
others
And so
this
the soil disturbance is important in
again keeping the area intact for the
soil food web and
uh making the
soil pore spaces stay
intact. Continually growing uh living
plants in the soil.
Uh this gets stated many times but it
can't be reiterated enough. Our soils
were built with perennials with a huge
root mass and of course we farm or in
our current production model we tend to
farm with annuals with a smaller root
mass and uh that leads to some issues
that we need to think about. uh a green
plant uh continually growing is
beneficial because again nature is a
constant feed process. Uh agriculture is
a extraction business. we're extracting
something and we need to be thinking in
terms of putting something back and of
course a continual growing live plant in
the soil does that and uh and
continually
uh builds soil aggregates and I'll show
you a a slide coming up that pertains a
little bit to that and of course uh
talking today this is a cover crop
summit and we know that cover crops can
fill in what otherwise would be a period
where nothing is growing and again gives
us an opportunity to continue bringing
carbon into the soil. This is a full
season cool season cover crop uh that we
raised at Oswalt uh that we planted and
raised up at the ranch. Uh it's we we do
different mixes uh periodically and u we
do switch to full season cool season
mixes uh at times and we find that uh
they work very well during the middle of
the grazing season uh right before our
breeding season which tends to be a
little bit later than than most
operations. Uh but still the the
philosophy is of course that we can have
a high energy high nutrient
uh mix in place where we can graze in
late July, early August. And uh then of
course we'll we'll we'll graze that by
managing it much the way we do all of
our perennials and our native and our
tame grass. and and we're actually
sometimes we're fortunate enough to
actually get another grazing on it later
in October or October and November uh if
the season allows us to do that. But uh
soil carbon again uh
most cropping systems and most rotations
cannot you cannot increase soil carbon
without the use of cover crops. And
we've seen that on our farm and ranch.
And uh again when you think about these
cool season cover crops
uh the below ground carbon allocation is
generally maximized during that first 4
to 8 weeks. And so a huge amount of
biomass
uh is not always required to be highly
effective in building soil aggregates
and and uh increasing carbon. And uh I
I've got some slides too. Here's an
example of a huge amount of biomass that
we all like to see. Again, this is
another full season warm season cover
crop uh on the Oswald Ranch. Again, when
I differentiate between cool seasons and
warm seasons, uh the species listed in
there, some of them are ve uh similar.
Uh most of them are not in the fact that
again when you look at the uh contents
of this mix. Uh this contains a lot of
warm season uh
uh species and this uh particular mix
generally is seated on our place from
the very oh the last week in May until
the middle of June. And our cool season
uh mixes we try to get in uh you know
midappril to you know maybe that first
week in June. And so we're we're
achieving different things. Uh again,
you can see the large biomass. It's fun
to hide in. Uh this is particular
pictures of just my two daughters uh
playing in the cover crop
uh a while back. And again, diversity is
the key. I think uh cover crops are all
good, even the simple ones, but I the
more diversity that we can get in there,
I think that more the uh microbes and
the soil food web, more of the soil food
web we can
feed because
again, when we manage holistically or
have that thought process, we're trying
to mimic nature. And when you look back
at the uh native population or the
native grasses, uh there was a huge huge
amount of diversity and that's what
we're trying to do with each of these
cover
crops. Continually growing plants in the
high tunnel. Uh I'm think Jay will t
touch on this a little bit, but I wanted
to show that uh again cover crops or
continually growing plants in the high
tunnel is important too. Uh not just uh
during the garden season, but uh
building
soils in the high tunnel as long as
possible and keeping a a green growing
uh
plant intact.
uh plant diversity. I touched on this a
little bit
uh can be accomplished by growing all
four crop types and I think we we miss
that some of the time with your warm and
cool season grasses and your warm and
season warm and cool season broad
leaves.
uh most is most effective to have a
rotation heavier in highcarbon plants uh
crops such as wheat or corn, not low
carbon crops like soybeans.
uh some of the diversity issues that we
deal with now are our corn and bean
rotations and I think that there's some
opportunity and we've shown that at the
Manoken Farm and with some individual
producers across the landscape in North
Dakota that we can add more diversity
into that rotation especially in with
the soybean realm and I think that
that's important and that kind of takes
away that angst, if you will, of
soybeans being a lowcarbon
uh crop. Uh we know this that highcarbon
plants build soils uh because again to
reiterate this, it brings additional
carbon into the soil profile and builds
the resiliency that we want in our
system. And the amount and quality of
carbon from crop residue contributes to
the amount of soil carbon. And it goes
back to our individual uh beginning
slides there with armor and uh having a
green growing plant as much as possible
and minimizing your disturbance. Again
to reiterate the soil health principles
are meant to be used in a system with a
systems approach and and I think that
that's important to remember. Uh every
green plant is a carbon inlet. Again,
we've harped on this quite a bit. Uh the
most potent tool with which to build a
healthy soil is a live plant. And uh I
think Lindsay again said this that
photosynthesis is the primary process
that feeds the soil. And so when I look
at myself as a manager of owner of
Oswald Ranch, essentially I manage
plants with photosynthesis and sunlight
and and so uh and then of course I
become a micro manager. Uh more
importantly than actually the cattle
that I raise and the crops I raise, I
deal with
photosynthesis and and managing
microbes. And uh we know that a cropping
system that creates these favorable
habitats and the one that will capture
the most energy from the
sun will resto uh excuse me will restore
soil health the quickest. And we often
get this question a lot regarding the
soil health principles.
Uh you know how quickly can we turn
things around? And my answer to them of
course is
always how much are you willing to how
many principles are you willing to
utilize? How many and how will you be
managing the principles? Because again,
they are universal, but they are very
unique and must be adapted to your
scenario. And that doesn't matter if
you're a farmer, a rancher, a uh
demonstration farm, a research farm, or
any of that. They all have to be adapted
uh to this to that situation.
Uh finally, livestock integration, which
is uh really uh one of my favorites or
my favorite of course near and dear
because of the livestock aspect and and
the ranching heritage uh that we have.
And again, we know that animals and the
plants and the soils have been uh
together since the beginning of time or
forever. And of course uh livestock
integration is important to balance
those carbon to nitrogen ratios
uh converting your highcarbon
uh crops if you will into the lowcarbon
organic
material
and livestock create the opportunity for
even more soil carbon. Uh this
particular photo is a actually out at
the Manokan farm and we're grazing uh
one of
our f full season cover crops. But the
simplification of the landscape and and
the the taking away of the livestock I
think
uh is vitally important. How do we know
if soil health is improving? Again, I
won't list all those things there, but
you can read them. And that's how we
look at things on our farm and ranch.
That's how we look at things at the
Manoken farm. Uh are we increasing uh
stability? Are we infiltrating water?
Uh decades ago, growing up, uh our water
cycle on our ranch, I believe, was
severely impaired or broken. uh and of
course I've worked to try to uh fix that
and of course uh or organic
matter increases are we seeing crop
response uh are we reducing inputs and
are we seeing an up upward trend this is
a a simple version of a manoken farm
from 2009 to 2020 on soil organic matter
uh if you you know there's many things
that help drive the system, but soil
organic matter seems to be a popular
one. And if you look across the graph
again, you'll see that field six has the
highest organic matter over
time. And we see this is the one field
that had the most crop diversity, uh,
the most used of cover crops and most
livestock integration. So that does
answer your question, how quickly or it
can be a a piece of the question or the
answer to the question uh how quickly
can we we change some things around and
uh and we know that when we implement
those principles of diversity uh and use
the cover crops and livestock
integration, we tend to see an upward
trend in uh what in the positive soil
attributes This is a soil organic matter
on Oswald Ranch from
2023. Um, this
was this particular field was a full
season cover crop field that I've been
experimenting with and I actually had a
annual crop uh in there in 2024. Uh, you
can see that there is some positive
things that are occurring. uh this
particular study was done by ECDIS and
uh was fortunate enough to be part of of
one of their studies and and I had two
fields that uh participated in that and
so I was pleasantly surprised to see
that we're seeing a a positive trend uh
upward and so we know that that things
are improving. This is the uh water
infiltration at Oswald Ranch again in
milliliters per second. And you can see
that we're able to infiltrate uh quite
well. I I don't know or I haven't
figured how that uh goes towards inches
uh per hour, but
uh we seem to have more severe uh rain
events at home or more impactful if you
will and we seem to be handling them uh
better than we ever did as far as
runoff. And again, the lighter events
were able to capture uh all the moisture
that we can. And and so
uh you know, you probably heard the the
the little funny that someone asked you
how much it rained and you used to say,
you know, well, half an inch or 20
hundreds or 3/4 of an inch. And now my
reply generally is I captured all of it.
Or how much did it rain? and I I got it
all. So, uh which is a good thing. This
is uh the corn crop on that particular
field. Uh this is my youngest daughter
Afton enjoying the day in the corn crop.
Uh this is a cover crop field or a soil
health field as I like to call it. Uh
that we were able to raise 110 bushel
corn on with
uh very limited inputs. Uh uh actually
uh it didn't have any fertility on it. I
I do attribute it to again 2024 being a
very good year as far as moisture and
that. But uh we were able to net, you
know, some pretty good profit off this
field because of our lack of uh inputs
on it. And this just kind of shows you
uh this is the same field that was in
2023. the organic matter uh has gone
down some. We we've used some of that
storage in the tank and uh but uh we've
got a plan to build it back up again and
uh we like to take a swing at the ball
every once in a while with these annual
crops and see how far our system uh with
using the soil health principles, how
far can we push it, how far can we drive
it. And of course with the armor on here
and stuff uh we were able to limit our
pesticide uh use as well. So we were
pretty pleased about that. Again using
the soil health principles and adapt
them to your production model. Uh you
know you can you can read through them
and
uh again keeping the soil covered
minimizing disturbance. uh good things
are going to happen if you can adapt
them to your production model and uh we
we've seen that uh over time at the
Minoan farm at Oswald Ranch at other
producers places again across the
landscape and uh and and so again the
soil health principles are are vital I
believe going forward to to help
mitigate some of these uh resource
concerns that we have across the state.
So, I think I'm pretty close to right
on. I might be a minute over. I
apologize for that. Uh but again, a
little self-education
uh slide uh
wmanfarm.com. And we do have a YouTube
channel and uh at Manokenfarm as well.
And thank you uh for uh listening today.
John, appreciate the presentation. Um,
like you, I'm doing a lot of the similar
stuff, grazing cattle.
I've got my and I'm curious of your
opinion and anybody else that wants to
chime in on this. Um, I got myself into
a situation this year where I've got
some additional land for grazing and it
was previously
uh uh silage corn fields. Um, and I'm
kind of being handed dead ground. Um
they had uh harvested the corn off of
it, put a very sparse winterkill cover
crop on it when they were done and it
sat bare all last season and now I'm
coming into it now. Um if I had time
during the winter, I may have, you know,
round bail grazed it to get some armor
on the soil or something. Um but now it
doesn't have much of anything.
Um, I have access to a lot of composted,
mostly composted wood chips. Um, and I
was thinking about spreading that on to
get some armor on the soil, but the
first thing that everybody says is that
all your nitrogen is going to get locked
up into it.
Um, I thought about possibly mixing that
with some poultry litter that I also
have available to me to at the same time
be putting nitrogen on it with that
armor and carbon. Uh, curious of your
guys' input.
I I guess first
off, I think the tie-up will depend on
how composted your wood chips are.
Uh, I think if they're a long way down
the road, you you'll probably be just
fine. Uh, you can put that on and
proceed. Uh, I don't have much
experience in poultry lure, Patrick, but
uh, I think it would act like other
manure when used uh, again, for lack of
a better term, responsibly. I would try
to get out there and get a cool season
cover crop on that on that ground if
you're able as quickly as possible and
then manage graze it and then get some
litter back on there and lay some of
that carbon
material on the ground on the
surface and then get that covered up
again. armor number one in in my book
and and again I that it's just how I
view things. But you need to get that
protected and covered and you can add
your compost if if you're in doubt. I
guess too you could get it tested. Uh
but you know, cool season uh cool season
mix on there with uh with quite a bit of
you know, cool season grass or something
that'll get you some biomass. Uh you
know, and then start working on your
legume and you know, your more fragile
peas and stuff later.
Yeah. the uh this situation where
because it was dead, there was no cover,
there was no living root system for
uh a year, um erosion took its toll and
because there's nothing uh holding the
ground together, you drive onto it uh
with a truck or any piece of equipment
and you kind of sink right away. Uh,
unfortunately I got to wait for drier
conditions before I could even get a
look at drilling in anything to it.
Okay. But yeah, I got myself into a heck
of a project.
Well, congratulations. I guess uh I mean
you're going to make it better. No
doubt. And and that landowner will will
thank you. Uh again, maybe keeping the
initial cover crop simple then if you're
facing some challenges. Uh but again,
try to get it in there when you can.
Uh and and get it protected, I think, is
the first thing. And then use the
livestock to get get the biomass to the
ground and and start building some
biology in there.